you probably know that the u.s. leads
the world in the most olympic medals won
the most number of Nobel laureates and
the most billionaires but we also leave
the world in some other ways not to brag
but we have the most incarcerated people
in the world
god bless the prison industrial complex
when it comes to obesity really the
global Mickey D's line a third of us
can't even see our own toads leading
nation and cheese production America
specifically probably Wisconsin
pew-pew we've got 90 guns for 100
persons sorry Yemen we be you in drones
and guns we make 89 percent of the
world's porn that makes porn as American
as church on Sunday Americans consume
80% of the world's painkillers make
sense though right I mean racism in this
country is a big pain in the ass
other developed nations can't compete
when we lead with the most number of
teen pregnancies per capita what what
credit card debt
grab your visa because we lead the world
in that too just think of all the air
miles so if anyone ever tells you
America's not that great just say God
bless the country with the most deaths
by lawnmower
you